context I recently uploaded a video that
was ten minutes long and consisted of me
doing nothing but eating cereal yes if
you haven't seen it yet don't worry it's
really it's really not vital viewing
most people haven't watched it most
people that clicked to watch the video
still I haven't seen it yet and the
reason that this video exists is because
someone left me a comment saying Charlie
you could literally eat cereal for ten
minutes and I would find entertaining I
saw that and I thought no you wouldn't
and I'm gonna prove it to you however
what I wasn't expecting was that
although most people yet thought it was
boring a large number of people left
comments saying that they did watch and
enjoy the whole video and it confused me
it piqued my curiosity at this point I
decided to compare the like dislike
ratio of the 10-minute video meeting
cereal which took me a morning to make
with my ten minutes short film the tea
chronicles which took me many many
months and its substantial amount of
money to make and it turned out people
did like my short film more yay but only
16% more which did leave me wondering
was it worth putting in all of that
extra effort my instinct has always told
me that the more effort you put into
something the more inherit worth that
they must have but I am starting to
wonder even that is actually true take
cutie pie for example he is someone who
a lot of people don't like because he is
incredibly successful so incredibly
successful for doing something that
seems very easy
he talks while playing video games
that's that's not hard right however
what I hadn't thought about before is
that even if his videos objectively take
less time and effort to put together
than a sketch or a short film or an
animation why does that mean that what
he does is less worthwhile because
clearly millions of people love what he
does and I feel like that should be
worth something with my cereal video
even though I tried to put a bit of
effort into it like I tried to light it
and frame it nicely and I added
background music throughout the whole
thing I made it and I still think it's
rubbish but when I see something like a
tumblr that is dedicated just to videos
of other people eating breakfast with me
remotely clearly someone is getting
something out of what I made I think
it's fair to say as well that
some of the people who hold that this
didn't take as much time to make in
therefore it is not as worthwhile
attitude think that about video blogging
I can completely sympathize with their
point of view as well given that a large
amount of video bloggers do seem to make
just content they will make videos about
vapid topics that don't feel like they
have any worth what confuses me about
that is the idea that you would write
off all of logging just because some
people don't use the medium in a way
that you'd like to me that is the same
as like writing off all of music because
you do not like pop songs the most
popular video that I've ever made was me
trying to do an American accent and
failing I and I did it because I
couldn't because I was busy that weekend
and I couldn't there anything else to do
it was a filler video but what I deemed
to be my most successful video is not
the one with the most views or even the
one with the highest production value
it's the one that allowed me to make the
strongest connection with the people who
did watch it in this case and insane
amount of ideo responses when it comes
to which video has more work I feel like
you could make a strong argument either
way like I prefer I'm scared but I know
a lot of people wouldn't have found me
and see in that video if it hadn't been
for my American accent so I don't know I
don't know when it happened but at some
point someone at YouTube decided that
they were going to call this all content
creators which is the blandest title I
think we all could possibly have hoped
for frankly I don't want to be making
content cuz that sounds to me like
something you're doing just to fill in
the gap on the flipside I don't feel
like I would ever be comfortable calling
what I do art I can't get over how
pretentious that sounds but what I do
worry is that as youtubers we may be
undervalue what we do most of the time
we are just making stuff in the hopes
that it will make someone else left and
that is it we're not looking for a deep
connection but I do genuinely think that
as youtubers we have the ability to make
stuff like nobody else can and I think
that people like us for it and surely
that is worth something
anyway that's what I've been thinking
about recently let me know what you
think and I'll see you later bye you've
just had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool
and the vlog has begun always tempted to
put the burps in see if I can avoid
putting in that one